[Music]
climate change today is something that
everyone should be concerned by we've
seen changes within not just our own
lifetimes but within the last 10 years
global sea levels back in the 1990s were
rising rate of about one point seven
millimeters per year but in recent
decade that rate has accelerated and sea
levels now rise on average by three
point two millimeters per year about 80
percent of the world's population live
around coastlines all over the world so
when ice melts and seen a rise it has
possibly
biodiversity in insect species is
decreasing and so this is loss of animal
life on planet Earth that we maybe don't
see with our eye on our own lives when
we know that there are things and
changes that are all in taking face then
it may be too late to stop so I think we
can all take measures now to try and
preserve the Earth's environment and to
reduce the effects of climate change
today making sure that the energy we do
use is clean is a step that we can all
really easily take
seeing the beauty of the natural world
it just proves to us that this is
something that's so valuable that if we
were to lose it we regret it supply
humans live on earth and so it's worth
fighting to preserve
[Music]
you